hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
it was dialogue the apology Socrates is
on trial for his life and he's trying to
explain his own position why it is that
he's doing the things that he's doing
and why people would would be
misinterpreting what he's doing and
something that would be bad for the the
people of Athens in particular for the
youth of Athens and like the Blues
Brothers is going to be kind of a silly
reference one of the things that he says
is I'm on a mission from God and that
takes up a good portion of his actual
defense so what does this actually mean
why did it come about that way
what does Socrates talking about with
with you know saying this as a defense
he starts out by telling us a story
about this friend of his as a young man
when Socrates himself is fairly young
Kyra fun yeah and he says that Kyra fun
goes to that Oracle at Delphi and the
Oracle at Delphi for the ancient Greeks
was one of the several places where you
could go to consult a representative of
the God and in this case you have a
priestess I'm not going to go into any
great details about this and you'd have
some sort of you know question usually
that's being given
then you know some sort of strange often
murky or mysterious response and you
know some of the famous question answers
that happened are you know when when
Croesus asks should I make war on Cyrus
of Persia and he receives the answer if
you do a great Empire shall be destroyed
he doesn't actually know that it's a
zone Empire so the god is is quite
Waffen and they would say the god Helios
in this case Apollo is giving answers
that are often enigmatic and that is
mysterious enigmatic sure the word form
for Riddler or mystery and it's up to
the person who receives the answer to
try to figure out what what does the God
actually mean what is this guidance
that's being provided in this case it's
not Socrates himself who is asking the
guy did somebody asking on his behalf
and it sets into a effect of course a
whole chain of events that eventually
going to lead to Socrates trial and
imprisonment and death
so Chiron goes and he asks a kind of
smartass question he says is anybody
wiser than socrates and they get a
one-word answer
nope nobody's wiser than socrates so
Socrates thinks about this and he says
what does that mean I mean I don't
consider myself particularly wise and
there's all sorts of people in my
culture and I talked about this in
another one of the core concepts you
know for example the politicians the
people in charge of the city who are
saying I actually know what the city of
Athens needs what will be beneficial to
her in the future how to avoid that
which will be harmful the poets the ones
who are passing down knowledge and
wisdom culturally and the craftspeople
the people who seem to actually know how
to make some particular thing happen
whether it's you know retail sales to
pottery to shoe making to organizing
households Socrates thinks to himself
yeah I don't know any of this sort of
stuff and yeah
nobody's wiser than me so what does the
God mean and this is going to lead like
I put here to doing philosophy and
philosophy at least in the way that
Plato is depicting it with respect to
Socrates in the way that Socrates
appears to have understood it is both an
attempt to figure out in his particular
case and his you might say existential
condition what a power what the the
Oracle means he says the God can't lie
so there must be some sort of truth
involved in this but I have no idea what
it would it actually is philosophy then
would be the process of trying to figure
out what that what that truth really is
and it's not you know a purely academic
practice it's something much more
on-the-spot
engaged it's still involving the
intellect it's still aiming after
knowledge or wisdom philosophy itself
means love of wisdom desire to have
wisdom and affinity with wisdom but it
doesn't actually make claims at least
with respect to Socrates to have to
possess wisdom and he's not only trying
to figure out who has wisdom he's trying
to figure out what is wisdom is wisdom
and art or skill or science or
discipline like the others like medicine
is or chariot driving is or generalship
is are these even themselves forms of
knowledge or where wisdom or are they
something else like you know being
successful in a certain way and then
kind of cobbling together a knack which
is what he takes rhetoric to be doing it
in other dialogues so Socrates goes
around and he takes this as charge from
the God to do something that would
strike you as a bit counterintuitive he
says let me see if I can prove the God
wrong now that's a weird way of
respecting the Oracle that's given to
you by the guy but that's exactly how he
describes it he says I set myself at
last with can
reluctance to check the truth of the
Oracle in the following way I went to
interview a man of the high reputation
for wisdom because I felt the year if
anywhere I should succeed in disproving
the Oracle and pointing out to my divine
authority said I was the wisest of men
but here is a man wiser than I am so you
know it's a weird way of justifying
oneself to say I'm on a mission from God
I'm obeying a kind of divine command or
divine bidding you know carrying out
what's in a divine message and yet
Socrates wants to try to disprove that
message he's putting it to the test he's
he is saying yeah there's got to be
somebody who's actually wiser than me
let me ask this guy let me ask this guy
and he goes from person to person to
person and I've discussed this in
another video so I'm not gonna talk
about it much here as it turns out all
of their pretensions to wisdom or to
knowledge turn out to be for the most
part baseless it turns out that the
craftsman actually do possess knowledge
within their skill area but that doesn't
translate to knowledge in general in
more universal terms this earns him a
lot of enmity people don't like to be
made fools of particularly when they
have high positions prestige respect and
what Socrates is doing is undermining
their claims to legitimacy to Authority
and to actually know what they're
talking about so this is a dangerous
activity yeah it gets him in trouble and
this is why he's actually on trial for
his life according to to his discussion
about the older accusers now Socrates
sees what he's doing as something like
being assigned to a battlefield position
and Socrates himself did in fact fight
in campaigns as a hoplite a heavy armed
soldier so you know makes sense for him
to speak in these terms he's also
addressing an audience of people who
themselves many of them have served in
in war and so it's a metaphor than that
they can understand for us we might
think in terms of being assigned a
certain difficult task not necessarily a
dangerous task but a difficult task
requires perseverance to stick to to
resist temptations to to cut corners to
to you know say I've had enough for
today I'm going home when the work isn't
isn't completely done so he looks at
what what he's doing is being assigned
as if from from a general on high to the
battle lines and what are the battle
lines those of the philosophical life
here here's another passage which
reflects this
he says the truth of the matter is this
gentleman when a man has once taken up
his stand either because it seems best
to him or in obedience to orders there I
believe he is bound to remain and face
the danger taking no account of death or
anything else before dishonor so there's
there's some sort of claim there's a
relationship between himself and and the
God and the truth that the God is
supposed to be somehow announcing or the
wisdom that the God has that Socrates
feels that he is being responsive to by
carrying out this this dangerous
practice of philosophizing which
includes going around and making enemies
of people an amazing high places he says
this being so it would be shocking
inconsistency on my part gentlemen when
the officers you chose to command me as
a when I was assigned my position at
Potidaea and then film am fellows
Amphipolis and Eliam I remained at my
post like anyone else and face death
actually we know from other dialogues
that Socrates not only stayed in the
line like everybody else but that he had
a lot more guts than most of the other
people and even on the retreat when a
lot of people were falling into disorder
he maintained order he actually saved
quite a few people so he says yeah
afterward when God appointed me as I
supposed and believed to the duty of
leading the philosophical life examining
myself and examining others I were then
through fear of death or any other
danger to desert my post he says that
would indeed be shocking if you wanted
to get me on the charge of atheism then
you would have me because I would be
practically
acting as if maybe if the gods do exist
I'm not going to pay attention to them
I'm not going to follow their charge
which has been given to me Socrates is
actually saying look I'm doing the
opposite of what I'm being charged with
I'm not being impious impiety I'm
actually being pious I am responding to
a divinely given message and incumbent
upon me duty that I didn't ask for but
now I've got it just like the guy who is
stuck out in that you know remote post
holding the pass he you know maybe he
got the unlucky straw or maybe he's
lucky because he's going to get glory
but it's up to him to hold that position
and and to fight so that's what Socrates
says he's going to do he's going to
continue the good fight and remember at
the time of the death is dialogue he's
been you know doing this for quite a
while he's an old man
what are his practices that go into this
philosophical life questioning himself
and others that's one of them he also
mentions the care of the soul and this
is a very important photonic and
Socratic notion that one ought to pay
attention not only to one's body not
only to one's possessions not only to
things like you know honour prestige
power these are all more or less
external what you really are is a soul
of soup a and you want to pay as much
attention to making sure that that
doesn't become corrupted or disordered
or out of whack because that's the one
thing you're actually going to retain
when your body dies when your
possessions are go on or you know passed
on to somebody else that's the you
according to the Platonic and Socratic
way of looking at things and really the
ancient Greek way of looking at things
in general you read The Odyssey or Iliad
and you see that sort of thing so that's
a central thing as well
questioning carry the soul
then he has this metaphor of the gastroc
and it's really quite quite striking so
it's worth reading he says this doesn't
just pertain to myself or to my friends
or to the people who are close to me
this pertains to the entire political
community that the the polis in this
case Athens he says it is literally true
even though it sounds rather comical
that God has specially appointed me to
this city as though it were a large
thoroughbred horse which because of its
great size is inclined to be lazy and
needs the stimulation of some stinging
flies is what a gadfly is it seems to me
that God has attached me to this city to
perform the office of such a fly and all
day long I never cease to settle here
there and everywhere rousing persuading
reproving every one of you you will not
easily find another like me gentlemen
and if you take my advice you'll spare
my life you could kill me with a single
slap but if you do that you're actually
removing from your very midst something
that has been given to you as a
political community as a city as a
community of values by the gods
themselves or by the God wholesales so
Socrates is making a very powerful case
here if you you know accept some of his
his premises he's saying that his
activity of philosophy itself is not
something that he originally you know
just just chose to do because he thought
it would be a great thing to go around
and question people he is actually
carrying out a religious task a
religious duty it remains you know for
us to think about whether this can be
translated into to not necessarily
completely Universal terms saying every
instance of philosophy is like this but
similarly existential terms asking is
that what philosophy could be for me do
do I have a charge to question myself to
get to know myself to question others to
to you no wonder about whether they add
you know what they purport to know to
take care of my own soul and exhort
others to take care of their soul and
perhaps even to take a role in political
cultural life of saying mmm I'm not sure
if that's the best thing to do
lets you know sting a bit and and
provoke and see if we can't get people
to think to question to try to work out
better solutions to so perhaps be a
little less selfish and self-centred now
the last thing that Socrates says which
is really interesting he says you know
you might not believe all this here's
the proof you're on the proof look at my
poverty if I really was in it for say
the money I'd be rich because I'm
extremely successful at going around and
asking people questions and deflating
people's egos and pretensions and
prestige and AD getting young people to
think about their souls and stuff like
that if that actually was a money-making
enterprise I'd be rolling in it but I'm
not so obviously I'm not in it for the
money obviously I'm in it for something
else some other reason he says does it
seem natural I should have neglected my
own affairs and endure the humiliation
of allowing my family to be neglected
all these years while i busied myself on
your behalf all this time going like a
father elder brother to see each one of
you privately urging you to set your
thoughts on goodness if I had got any
enjoyment from it if I'd been paid for
my good advice then you could explain it
away you could say yeah he's just in it
for whatever he's getting out of it
that's not the case I'm not actually
doing it just because I get a kick out
of it I'm certainly not making any money
at it
he says the witness that I can offer to
prove the truth is my poverty it may
seem curious I go around giving advice
like this and busying myself but that's
because I am subject to a divine or
supernatural charge
is the defense that Socrates is making
for himself there's a little bit more to
say about Socrates Plato and religion
not only in this dialogue but running
through the other dialogues but that's
where the crux of his argument
explaining what he's doing as a
philosopher justifying his practices in
terms of a divine colleague